it's no secret Matt R's audience is made
up of majority women primarily young
women who were first introduced to
standup comedy through Matt's viral
online clips and are all expecting to
hear flirty crowd work but when they
instead get a domestic abuse joke this
type of aftermath is kind of predictable
a lot of his fans haven't been exposed
to much standup if any and struggle to
comprehend the concept of the intent
behind the words mattering more than the
words themselves you can tell by who he
is by the way he delivers jokes by the
way he does his crowd work he goes in
but in the most nonserious way look at
their intent the intent is to make you
laugh I promise you Matt R is a very
respectful young man he's not out
beating people he's not pro- domestic
violence and that joke is not making
anybody go home and hit their wife yeah
you
touchy [__]